on september 12 2017 tim cook came out
on stage and revealed apple's iphone 10
which came with the groundbreaking new
face id authentication system that we
all know and love today but
unfortunately it required apple to cut
out a notch out of the display to fit in
their full array of true depth sensors
including the dot projector that
projects a ton of little dots onto your
face which are then scanned by the
infrared camera to measure the depth of
your facial features and confirm that it
is in fact you who's unlocking the
iphone and now four years later face id
works great and all but people are
honestly getting sick of seeing this
huge notch on their iphone while the
competition like samsung's galaxy vol 3
is already using under display camera
technology that definitely isn't perfect
due to the horrible camera quality but
it's definitely way ahead of apple's
massive notch so with that said apple's
new smaller notch on the iphone 13 is
both a good thing and a bad thing
because while we're all happy that the
notch is getting smaller we all honestly
wish apple would have gotten rid of it
completely by now so in this video i'm
gonna share the truth about what apple
is doing with the smaller notch and why
including how this changes everything
for the future when apple eventually
switches to a new cutout design before
getting rid of it completely so let's
get started first off if you're
wondering why apple is taking so long to
get rid of the notch i need to teach you
a little lesson about how apple does
marketing the most important thing about
how apple designs their products is that
they stand out from the crowd when you
see this in somebody's ears you know
it's a pair of airpods 100 guaranteed no
doubt about it when you see a computer
like this you know it's an imac due to
the iconic chin that many people wish
apple would get rid of but they won't
when you see this pair of headphones
you know it's apple's airpods max due to
the all-aluminum finish the color scheme
and the unique headband design when you
see this watch on somebody's wrist you
know it's an apple watch and when you
see a smartphone with a notch that looks
like this you know it's an iphone 100
guaranteed even from a block away so yes
apple likes to make their products stand
out and to do that sometimes their
designs can be a little bit shocking
like the original airpods which
countless people made fun of but it's
the very reason why they went viral
people also went crazy over the
tripophobic triple lens design on the
back of the iphone 11 but it stands out
from the rest of the camera bump designs
on the market so if you're wondering why
apple is keeping the notch around on the
iphone 13 i have a couple of very good
reasons for it obviously the notch is
gonna help the iphone continue to stand
out from the crowd which apple loves to
do but on the other hand the smaller
notch is gonna appeal to a lot of the
iphone users who have been waiting for
that design change before upgrading
again since it's gonna make it look
quite a bit better and the other good
reason that people forget about is that
apple needs to continue selling iphones
for the next decade so if they
completely got rid of the notch in just
one year there's gonna be nothing left
for them to change or improve the next
year so from apple's perspective they
need to carefully improve the display
and the notch on the iphone over the
course of a few years so they have a
clear path of upgrade ability to be able
to extract more sales and profits but
with all that said and out of the way i
want to now get into the details about
this notch that are going to be
incredibly important for the future if
you look at the design of the smaller
notch you'll see that the absolutely
biggest change is the relocation of the
speaker grille up to the top of the
phone right underneath the frame if you
think about it if apple was to create a
completely notchless phone in the future
the speaker grille absolutely had to be
moved up to the top which they've
thankfully already done on the iphone
13. so this is a very important step to
get rid of the notch completely on top
of that way back in january it was
reported that apple would be redesigning
the face id sensor system by integrating
three of the main truedepth sensors into
just one camera module to enable the
smaller knot size and this has recently
been confirmed by john prosser who was
able to get his hands on images of a new
device that apple is handing out to
employees that features the brand new
face id system and that actually matches
up to the leaked notch photos that we've
seen in the past and the reason why
apple is handing this out to employees
is because apparently the new face id
system is going to work with masks which
is by far the biggest complaint that
people have with face id and it's also
the main reason why people are asking
for in-display touch id but the truth is
if apple is able to make face id work
with mass then there's really no reason
for touch id anymore at least in my
opinion but the point that i'm trying to
make is that apple is working on
consolidating the face id system into
less and less cutouts which is gonna
greatly help them in the future when
they try to completely go notchless and
if you really think about it the lidar
scanner on the back of the iphone is
basically a face id sensor system built
into just one cutout so i fully expect
apple to do this with the front of the
display with face id but now i want to
get into a major leak that i've recently
discovered that apparently nobody is
talking about according to the
lesser-known leaker shrimp apple pro his
sources are claiming that the iphone 14
is gonna have a double punch hole notch
design and if this sounds absolutely
crazy to you check out this leak from a
few months back from ming chi quo who is
a pretty reliable analyst he said that
some 2022 iphone 14 models are gonna
abandon the notch in favor of a punch
hole display
matching up to the other leak and if you
think about it apple is not going to be
able to put all those sensors into just
one cutout so they need a double cutout
design and if you're wondering what
that's going to look like philip
vabrosic on twitter created a render of
the double cutout showing what it could
potentially look like and i could
definitely agree that it looks better
than the notch and it also looks unique
compared to other phones out there but
then the big game changer leak was when
shrimp apple pro leaked an image of a
prototype iphone 14 display panel that
could actually be legit
but of course this isn't coming from a
reputable leaker so we can't really take
it too seriously and going further
apparently minxiko believes that at
least one iphone 15 model in 2023
is gonna have a completely notchless
design which would mean that the sensors
are going underneath the display but in
my opinion i don't know if i agree with
both the leaker and ming chi quo about
this whole new punch hole design coming
to the iphone 14 and a notchless design
coming to the iphone 15. to me it
doesn't make sense for apple to spend
three years with the same exact notch on
the iphone 10 through 12 only to
redesign the notch and make it smaller
on the 13 and then switch to a cutout
design for the 14 and then go completely
notchless for the 15. moving at such a
quick pace doesn't really sound like
something apple would do so in my
opinion it makes sense for the iphone
13's smaller notch to also come on the
iphone 14 because we already know that
the 14 is going to be focused on massive
camera improvements including a 48
megapixel camera that can shoot 8k video
and then the iphone 15 will probably
come with this new dual cutout design
and then the completely nauseous design
will come sometime after that but either
way all of this can only be made
possible by the huge changes that apple
is making to the iphone 13's notch by
moving the speaker up to the top of the
phone and consolidating a bunch of face
id sensors into one so with that i'm
excited to see what the future holds for
the iphone if you enjoyed this video go
ahead and tap the like button and click
the circle button to subscribe for more
videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]